a very confused and swollen looking
failed former president Donald Trump is
promising a global trade war that would
be disastrous for the American economy
in his latest teleprompter tirade
remember Barack Obama was bad for using
a teleprompter Obama but Trump is I
guess good for using a teleprompter I
don't know this is Trump's new series of
quote policy statements where he's
laying out supposed policy that he will
enact if he becomes president of the
United States I can see why Republicans
are running away from talking about
policy because every idea is a complete
and total disaster will
um let's just jump into this thing in
the middle here is Trump announcing
truly just a whacked global trade war
that would not be good for the American
economy take a look at this we will
phase in a system Universal Baseline
tariffs on most foreign products on top
of this higher tariffs will increase
incrementally depending on how much
individual foreign countries devalue
their currency they devalue their
currency to take advantage of the United
States as tariffs are did you notice
that jump cut there and farm producers
go up taxes on American Producers will
go down and go down very substantially
and that means a lot of jobs coming in
not only will this system end our gaping
trade deficits and they are massive
right now gaping and bring back millions
of American jobs it will also bring
trillions and trillions of dollars
pouring into the United States Treasury
from foreign countries that allow us to
invest that money in American workers I
will Implement a bold series of reforms
to completely eliminate dependence on
China in all critical areas we will
revoke China's most favored nation trade
status and adopt a four-year plan to
phase out all Chinese Imports of
essential Goods everything from
Electronics to Steel to Pharmaceuticals
we will also adopt new rules to stop U.S
companies from pouring investments into
China and to stop China from buying up
America allowing all of those
Investments That clearly Serve American
interests we're not going to allow bad
things to happen to our country anymore
it's bad all right so listen this guy is
clueless about trade now on there's
there's so much here genuinely the first
thing about this is the entire framing
of this trade and tariff story is that
there's no cost to doing this stuff of
course bring the supply chains home hire
American buy American build American
these are completely reasonable economic
nationalist ideas that I could get
behind and it there not bad ideas in
some theoretical sense but people like
Trump and many and all Republicans and
many Democrats as well they pretend that
there's no other side to this thing and
also they pretend like this will
obviously create American jobs now first
and foremost the tariffs that Trump did
with Chinese products while he was
President a recent study found
that the totality of that trade policy
cost the U.S about 250 million jobs okay
you can find that study you can read
about it it's it's sort of a technical
paper maybe there's a summary of it but
it didn't actually create jobs it cost
the United States jobs that's number one
it's not the silver bullet on jobs that
Trump believes it to be but what Trump
and others never tell you is by the way
if we do this
things will be insanely more expensive
on the one hand they complain about
inflation and how much eggs cost and how
much everything costs that to find
complaint you can if things are too
expensive it's perfectly reasonable to
complain but then out of the other side
of their mouths they say we're going to
produce everything here
but they don't mention how expensive
everything's going to be the United
States through a series of cumulative
decisions over the last 40 to 50 years
has decided and when I mean we've
decided it's not
Reagan decided or Clinton decided it's
the totality of our policy has been
based on the idea that we prefer cheap
stuff rather than paying more but making
it all here in the United States
if all of these things Trump is talking
about
were manufactured here in the United
States
at least he's saying it's a 40-year plan
because it'll take 40 years to actually
make all of that happen and completely
restructure all of these Supply chains
at least he's being honest but it will
become insanely more expensive and
people already can't afford the
inflation we've seen while still being
heavily dependent on China for cheap
stuff which we prefer and when I say we
prefer what I mean is our economy is
built on that so the global trade war
that Trump is talking about will never
happen and if it did it would be insane
what it would do to prices in this
teleprompter you know deranged
teleprompter speech uh Trump also of
course attacked Joe Biden here's the
beginning of it we'll just look at a
little more Joe Biden claims to support
American manufacturing but in reality
he's pushing the same pro-china
globalist agenda that ripped the
industrial heart out of our country he's
really not it ripped us apart Biden and
the globalist support raising remember
globalists does Trump even know what
that means no is it often just a way to
say Jews yes it's it's meaningless guys
X is an American production they support
more crippling regulations Killing
American jobs they support skyrocketing
domestic energy costs and they support
massive anti-American multinational
agreements that send our wealth and
factories overseas it's just a word
salad and remember here Trump bemoans
regulations the Trump Administration
eliminated some obama-era regulations on
rail which could be a factor in the East
Palestine train derailment so on the one
hand he bemoans regulations on the other
hand his supposed reduction of
regulations was actually very very
destructive it's very dangerous stuff
and tomorrow we're going to get a quote
from Ruth Ben geot who's been a guest on
the program where she says that that
whether it's Trump or DeSantis the
authoritarian direction that this stuff
is going in is extraordinarily dangerous
I like wine but I know very little about
it and I'm completely clueless when I go
to a wine shop I just don't know what
I'm looking for I don't know what I'm
looking at I couldn't tell you anything
about varietals or if there's hints of
Persimmon or any of it and so if you're
like me wishing you had a seasoned
expert by your side when you're choosing
wine crunchy red fruit is the answer
crunchy red fruit delivers Choice
handcrafted small production wines right
to your door every bottle is hand-picked
by owner and master sommelier Jackson
rohrbaugh in Seattle and comes with food
pairing suggestions we've been chatting
with Jackson his curating puts an
emphasis on organic low intervention
wines wines without artificial yeasts or
chemicals crunchy red fruit sources from
small scale sustainable Vineyards and
only wines that are true to their
location and grape crunchy red fruits
bi-monthly wine club is called the
circle every two months you'll get three
or six bottles to enjoy with videos to
help you appreciate what you're drinking
go to crunchyredfruit.com use the code
Pacman for twenty dollars off a single
purchase or if you join their bi-monthly
wine club send a message to circle
crunchyredfruit.com after you sign up
and they'll take twenty dollars off your
first shipment the link is down below